Jake: 看表了
Jake: Look at the watch.
Alice:坐后边玩手机
Alice: Sitting in the back, playing with my phone.
Alice:感觉晕车了
Alice: Feeling car sick.
其他人：嗯过了
Others: Yeah, we passed it.
Jake: 到了是吧
Jake: We're here, right?
Jake: 确实到了
Jake: We are indeed here.
Jake:进去
Jake: Let's go in.
Jake:进去进去找
Jake: Let's go in and look.
Jake:拐拐拐
Jake: Turn, turn, turn.
其他人：够荒凉的
Others: It's pretty desolate.
Jake: 咱也不知道这是啥地
Jake: We don't even know what place this is.
其他人：嗯信号不好
Others: Yeah, bad signal.
Jake: 皇家新村
Jake: Royal New Village.
其他人：信号不好啊
Others: The signal is bad, huh?
其他人：走了呢
Others: We're moving.
其他人：应该就是这100米啊
Others: It should be just 100 meters ahead.
Jake: 那行吧
Jake: Alright then.
其他人：是不就这
Others: Is it just this place?
Shure:  好像不是这个
Shure: Seems like it's not this one.
Jake: 呃
Jake: Uh.
Shure:  再往前大铁门
Shure: Keep going ahead, there's a big iron gate.
其他人：不是这个
Others: It's not this one.
Jake: 我我等会
Jake: I'll, I'll wait a bit.
Jake: 我我我这边看看
Jake: I'll, I'll check over here.
Jake: 我这边也有地图可以看
Jake: I have a map I can check too.
Alice:是65号
Alice: It's number 65.
Jake: 往前走往前走一会
Jake: Walk ahead a bit.
其他人：信号不好
Others: Bad signal.
Jake: 就这个就左边这个
Jake: It's this one, the one on the left.
Shure:  对这个口停就行
Shure: Yeah, stop at this entrance.
Shure:  开一下我这侧门
Shure: Open my side door.
其他人：好嘞
Others: Got it.
Jake: 都开吧
Jake: Open all the doors.
其他人： 这边手动的啊
Others: This side is manual.
Alice:我看手机了
Alice: I'm checking my phone.
Alice:难受
Alice: Feeling sick.
Shure:  哎呦呦怎么还迷糊了呢
Shure: Oh, why are you feeling dizzy?
Katrina:  我猜是往这吧
Katrina: I guess we go this way.
Alice:前
Alice: Forward.
Shure:  再往前是吗
Shure: Further ahead, right?
Shure:  是吗
Shure: Really?
Alice:前
Alice: Forward.
Tasha: 一样的标志
Tasha: The same sign.
Tasha: 再往前
Tasha: Go further.
Alice:还得往前
Alice: Still need to go further.
Tasha: 往前
Tasha: Forward.
Jake: 你家是刚刚有猫吗
Jake: Did you just get a cat at home?
Shure:  多少多少啊
Shure: How much, how much?
Alice:咪咪
Alice: Mimi.
Tasha: 哪呢
Tasha: Where?
Shure:  不是如果你摁对了
Shure: No, if you press it right.
Shure:  他直接自己开
Shure: It will open by itself.
Alice:咪咪
Alice: Mimi.
Jake: 你你要先按一个键
Jake: You need to press a key first.
Tasha: 哎
Tasha: Hey.
Jake: 在在对你等到他
Jake: And then wait for it.
Jake: 哔对
Jake: Beep, right.
Jake: 耶
Jake: Yeah!
Jake: 牛啊牛啊
Jake: Awesome, awesome.
Shure:  哦太牛了
Shure: Oh, so awesome.
Shure:  人类居然可以记住6位密码
Shure: Humans can actually remember a 6-digit password.
Shure:  小心点那有那有
Shure: Be careful, there, there.
Shure:  钉子好像
Shure: Looks like a nail.
Jake: 经过了3天的训练
Jake: After 3 days of training.
Shure:  人类记住这串密码需要3天的训练
Shure: It takes humans 3 days of training to remember this password.
Shure:  AI 3秒用吗
Shure: AI takes 3 seconds, right?
Jake: 三秒开玩笑
Jake: Three seconds, you're kidding.
Shure:  3毫秒
Shure: 3 milliseconds.
Lucia: 这么简单的事情就不用3秒了是吧
Lucia: Such a simple thing doesn't even need 3 seconds, right?
Shure:  小艾特他没有开灯
Shure: Little Aite, he didn’t turn on the light.
Jake: 3秒带开机吗
Jake: Three seconds, including booting?
Jake: 三秒开机
Jake: Three seconds to boot.
Jake: 放冰箱放完冰箱就结束
Jake: Put it in the fridge, once you put it in the fridge, it's done.
Lucia: 我的留言板
Lucia: My message board.
Lucia: 不是留言板
Lucia: Not a message board.
Lucia: 就是那个软木的那个照片墙
Lucia: It's that cork photo wall.
Katrina:  这个肉要腌吗
Katrina: Does this meat need to be marinated?
Katrina:  还是说先放冰箱
Katrina: Or should we put it in the fridge first?
Alice:哎呦我想吐
Alice: Oh, I feel like throwing up.
Tasha: 啊我要喝水
Tasha: Ah, I need some water.
Lucia: 它怎么这么大呀
Lucia: Why is it so big?
Lucia: 我以为它就一点点呢
Lucia: I thought it would be just a little bit.
Lucia: 装起来就好
Lucia: Just pack it up.
Katrina:  把肯德基扔了
Katrina: Throw away the KFC.
Shure:  我每天放冰箱的意义
Shure: What's the point of putting it in the fridge every day?
Shure:  就是留一天扔掉是吗
Shure: Just to throw it away the next day, right?
Shure:  好饿好饿
Shure: So hungry, so hungry.
Shure:  好困好困好累好累
Shure: So sleepy, so sleepy, so tired, so tired.
Jake: 好空
Jake: So empty.
Katrina:  鸡蛋呢
Katrina: Where are the eggs?
Katrina:  扔了
Katrina: Thrown away.
Shure:  放放放
Shure: Put, put, put.
Shure:  导完
Shure: Finished transferring.
Shure:  导完就
Shure: Finished transferring and then...
Lucia: 再不吃可能坏了
Lucia: If we don't eat it soon, it might go bad.
Jake: yes yes
Jake: Yes, yes.
Shure:  为什么他要听RMB
Shure: Why is he listening to RMB?
Jake: 啊
Jake: Huh?
Shure:  这个小狗
Shure: This little dog.
Jake: RNB
Jake: RNB.
Lucia: 哦对芒果
Lucia: Oh right, mango.
Alice:这能喝的水吗
Alice: Is this water drinkable?
Shure:  不用不用
Shure: No need, no need.
Shure:  电子版扫描就行
Shure: Just a digital scan will do.
Tasha:这 门被开过了
Tasha: This door has been opened.
Tasha: 你刚开的是吧
Tasha: You just opened it, right?
Lucia: 我们晚上可以把
Lucia: Tonight we can...
Katrina:  这4个吃了吧
Katrina: Eat these four, right?
Lucia: 让我们那啥
Lucia: Let us...
Lucia: 做那些甜品的时候需不需要用
Lucia: Do we need to use them for those desserts?
Jake: 吃
Jake: Eat.
Jake: 今晚做什么呀
Jake: What are we making tonight?
Katrina:  对这个吗
Katrina: This one?
Tasha: 都可以
Tasha: Either is fine.
Jake: 你你烤他甜点
Jake: You, you bake his dessert.
Lucia: 可以先放一下
Lucia: You can put it aside first.
Lucia: 然后如果用不着了再把它吃掉
Lucia: And if we don't need it, we can eat it later.
Jake: 这个
Jake: This one.
Jake: 热量爆炸是吧
Jake: The calories are going to explode, right?
Lucia: 芒果
Lucia: Mango.
Lucia: 怎么给我一种好像要尽快吃它的感觉
Lucia: Why do I feel like we need to eat it quickly?
Jake: 今天就吃
Jake: Let's eat it today.
Tasha: 那就今天就吃
Tasha: Then let's eat it today.
Jake: 今天今天围绕着他能做什么
Jake: Let's see what we can make with it today.
Katrina:  was ice cream
Katrina: Was it ice cream?
Tasha: 什么都行
Tasha: Anything works.
Lucia: 对会今天把它做了
Lucia: Yeah, let's make something with it today.
Jake: 对今天围绕着他
Jake: Yes, let's focus on it today.
Shure:  我我们我可以
Shure: I, we, I can...
Shure:  我们可以养小芒果
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
Jake: 哈哈哈芒果核这个我知道
Jake: Hahaha, the mango pit, I know about that.
Shure:  哈哈哈知道那个吗
Shure: Haha, you know about that, right?
Alice:就那个芒果盒
Alice: Yeah, that mango pit.
Tasha: 芒果皮芒果狗是吧嗯
Tasha: Mango skin, mango dog, right?
Shure:  芒果核对
Shure: The mango pit, yes.
Lucia: 哦没反应过来
Lucia: Oh, I didn't get it at first.
Alice:让他把它嗦嗦嗦
Alice: Let him suck it clean.
Lucia: 哎我鞋带没有开
Lucia: Oh, my shoelace isn't untied.
Shure:  对嗦嗦干净点
Shure: Yeah, suck it clean.
Lucia: 行今天晚上的活动就是养小小芒果
Lucia: Alright, tonight's activity is raising a little mango.
Jake: 好的好的
Jake: Okay, okay.
Alice:这个放冰箱
Alice: This goes in the fridge.
Lucia: 芒果核
Lucia: The mango pit.
Shure:  不行今天太多了
Shure: No, there's too much today.
Shure:  明天明天养吧
Shure: Let's do it tomorrow.
Katrina:  因为他那个可能
Katrina: Because maybe...
Shure:  工作量爆棚了有点
Shure: Too much workload today.
Jake: 养芒果要工序很多吗
Jake: Does raising a mango take a lot of steps?
Shure:  啊不需要需要
Shure: Ah, not really, it does.
Lucia: 用就一直搁那吸那个芒果盒就行了
Lucia: Just keep it there and keep sucking the mango pit.
Jake: 一直吃是吧
Jake: Keep eating it, right?
Shure:  嗦干净一点就好
Shure: Suck it clean.
Lucia: 然后洗一洗
Lucia: Then wash it.
Jake: 好的好的
Jake: Okay, okay.
Jake: 迷惑行为是吧不知道
Jake: It's confusing behavior, right? I don't know.
Shure:  人类为什么会把一个植物的种子
Shure: Why would humans take a plant's seed
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Shure:  当成一个宠物
Shure: and treat it like a pet?
Shure:  why human will
Shure: Why would humans do that?
Jake: 您好
Jake: Hello.
Jake: 6:11
Shure:  我靠那是7点 能吃啊
Shure: Oh man, that's 7 o'clock. Can you eat that?
Tasha: 7点
Tasha: 7 o'clock.
Jake:可拉到
Jake: Oh, come on.
Jake: 7点开始做
Jake: Start at 7.
Alice:开始做快8点吃
Alice: Start at 7, eat around 8.
Shure:  能快速的把我这个先导完吗
Shure: Can you quickly finish this for me first?
Jake: 哈哈哈呃没没法快
Jake: Hahaha, there's no way to do it quickly.
Tasha: 哎牛奶怎么拿出来了
Tasha: Hey, why is the milk out?
Alice:是早上的时候吧
Alice: Maybe from the morning?
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
Alice:没事
Alice: It's fine.
Lucia: 现在应该还不至于坏
Lucia: It shouldn't be bad yet.
Tasha: 放冰箱里吧
Tasha: Let's put it in the fridge.
Jake: 蛋液怎么会呢
Jake: How could the egg liquid go bad?
Shure:  那可以停了吗这个先
Shure: Can we stop this for now?
Jake: 结束了吧结束了吧
Jake: Is it over? Is it over?
Shure:  结束了吧
Shure: Is it over?
Shure:  我这个快结束
Shure: I'm almost done with this.
Jake: 来快快结束
Jake: Come on, let's finish quickly.